[Music]
And you're watching I'd Like to Know,
our Bible question and answer program
here at Secrets Unsealed and Some TV.
And thank you for sharing just a little
of your busy day with us. My name is CA
Murray. I'm in the company of Pastor
Steven Bor, our president and founder.
Pastor, good to have you here. It's a
blessing to work with you. And Pastor
David Salazar who superintends our
Latino channel and work here at Secrets
and Seal and 7 TV. Pastor, always good
to share the desk with you. Thank you,
pastor. As we mentioned, this is our
Bible question and answer program
quickly. If you want to get a question
in, we'd love to have you do so by
writing to
tvsumtv.org. That is
tvsums as in
marytv.org. and we will get to your
questions just as quickly as we possibly
can. Pastor Salazar, if you would open
us up with prayer, we'll go to our first
question and move right up. Absolutely.
Let's pray.
Heavenly Father, we are coming before
you with humble hearts, knowing Lord
that it is you, the author of all things
and the uh the the one that has all the
understanding and all the knowledge that
can provide to us as uh your vessels the
understanding and the words to respond
to the questions that are being sent by
your people. I pray that you will help
us today. Be with us. Be with our words
that we may re be able to share things
that come according to your will and to
your word so that the questions can be
answered uh with the power of the Holy
Spirit and from on high. And I pray this
in Jesus name. Amen. Amen. Amen. Our
first question comes to us from David.
We don't have a location. We want to
encourage you if you uh would be so
please just let us know where you're
writing from. It gives us an idea of the
footprint, our coverage, where people
are watching and uh that just helps us
uh with that information so very very
much. But David, we look at your
question now. I have a friend who
believes in Judaism and he says that the
prophecies that we as Christians use to
speak of Christ as Messiah do not speak
of Christ. He gives the example of Hosea
chapter 1, chapter 11 verse one. And
Pastor D, I'm going ask you to uh look
that up as we begin to read. Mhm. Uh
which is referenced in Matthew 2:15.
Pastor uh Boris, if you would uh begin
turning there as I continue to read, and
not speaking of the Messiah, but of
Israel. Psalms 22:1, which is cited by
Christ on the cross as taken out of
context. and that Isaiah 53 actually
speaks of Israel and not Christ and
others that he claims are taken out of
context which uh what can I do and how
can I explain to him that these
prophecies actually speak of the Messiah
and how can I tell him that they are
they are not uh taken out of context.
It's interesting that uh just two weeks
ago I had the same I'll say argument
discussion with a person who used the
same text and came with the same line of
reasoning but this the person that I was
talking to uses this to reject Christ
totally. He says we don't need Christ at
all. So his problem is much deeper uh
and we had to go into the night dealing
with that. But he used the same line of
reasoning and argument to say that
Christ is unnecessary and that those
prophecies do not refer to Christ. they
refer to Israel. So, let's sort of walk
our way through that. Uh, Pastor Dave,
if you if you would give us Hosea 11
verse one, and I read here Hosea 11:1,
when Israel was a child, I loved him,
and out of Egypt I called my son.
All right. And Pastor Boore, you want
Matthew 2:15?
Basically repeats the same thought. Uh
let's read verse 14 for the context.
When he arose
uh that's Joseph, he took the young
child and his mother by night and
departed for Egypt and was there until
the death of Herod that it might be
fulfilled which was spoken by the Lord
through the prophet saying out of Egypt
I called my son.
All
right. There are prophecies in the Bible
that have dual application as well as
due fulfillment. And that's one of the
things that we're we're dealing with
here.
Um yeah, let me stop there. Um and
because I've got something else to say
take a little bit longer. Um any of you
want to jump in at this point? Okay.
We're dealing with typology here. Uh you
know, there are many many instances in
the Bible of type and anti-ype. the Old
Testament, you have the lamb, the
fulfillment is in Christ. You have the
Passover fulfillment in Christ. You have
all of these cases where uh typology is
used as a method to connect something in
the Old Testament with something in the
New. Uh you know, God gave Abraham a
prophecy of 400 years. And that prophecy
said that uh God's people were going to
be transferred to Egypt. Mhm. Uh and
they were going to be there for 400
years and then they would return to the
promised land. Right. That is used as a
type of what happened with Christ.
Christ was transferred to Egypt and then
God called Jesus out of Egypt to come
back to Canaan. And so you have type and
anti-ype. Now the type is never as fully
u pictured as the antitype right you
know Christ and I don't intend to be
irreverent Christ is not a four-legged
creature okay Christ is not a lamb
literally so the type is not the same as
the antitype but they're similar and so
what you have here is a type in the old
testament what happened to Israel and
that is used to refer to Christ in the
gospel of Matthew
Another interesting thing is that you
know our friend David is is I mean I'm
glad that he's trying to reach and
trying to connect with his friends and
one of them who believes in Judaism.
It's it's sort of experiencing his David
experiencing the same type of rejection
that a lot of the apostles and even
Christ himself had to deal with from the
Jewish of his of his time, you know,
from the Jewish people of his time, the
nation as a whole uh sort of rejected
because the leadership, the the rabbis
and the Pharisees and those that were
leading rejected Jesus. they they sort
of put the emphasis in the
traditions over the word of God. And one
of the things that I will encourage
David to do is to um you know to
continue to search with his friend based
on the scripture and based on the
studying of the scripture so that he can
like
Christ go through all the references
that deal with Jesus and his work. I I
particularly find that uh maybe some of
these verses and and and there is been a
lot of debate um among Jew you know
Jewish leaders even today in regards to
these verses and a lot of them kind of
say the same thing oh this is this verse
is applied you know for Israel or this
verse is applied not for Jesus as does
as the Christians say and so there's a
lot of these things already there's
arguments that are made but if if you
are able to talk with him and study
together and I will say that One of the
books that I find harder for for a lot
of you know these arguments to be made
against is actually the book of Daniel.
When you study the book of Daniel you
really a lot of the arguments that are
are common are not are not valid there.
A lot of you know Jewish scholars don't
like Daniel for that purpose because
Daniel sort of points even by time frame
puts the the coming of the Messiah right
at the time of where Jesus came. So I
think that maybe as I encourage David to
continue to study the scriptures with
this individual. Hopefully he's opened
to study the scriptures, but you have to
remember also that like Paul mentions in
2 Corinthians 3:13 and I would like to
go there. 2 Corinthians 3 uh
13-15. I I I hope he understand this in
the right way and I'm going to share the
verses here. Paul is speaking in regards
to what happens to some of the Jewish
and of his time. It says, "Unlike Moses
who put on a who put a veil over his
face so that the children of Israel
could not look steadily at the end of
what was passing away, but their minds
were blinded. For until this day, the
same veil remains unlifted in the
reading of the Old Testament because the
veil is taken away in Christ. But even
to this day when Moses is read a veil
lies on their heart. So unfortunately
for a lot of the people that are in
Judaism or believe in Judaism there's a
veil in their hearts. They don't want to
really read the study of the scriptures
with an open mind. And I think that you
have to pray and say Lord help me as I
share with this individual that his veil
is open because the veil is Christ.
Christ, you know, when you understand
and you see the Jesus in the Old
Testament, you truly will embrace the
fact of of of the you know, of the of
the gospels or the rather the Bible. The
Old Testament speaks of Jesus time and
time again. So I I pray that you uh that
David understands that there is a veil
that a lot of times people have and uh
God wants to remove that veil through
Christ so that they may be able to
understand fully what the Bible says.
You know the bottom line is let's take
the other two examples that are
presented in this question. Uh you have
Psalm 22 verse1 that is mentioned. Yeah.
And you have Isaiah
53. So when you look at Psalm 22, it's a
a psalm of David. Mhm. There's no
experience in the life of David that
fulfilled this psalm.
Absolutely none.
uh you know it says uh that he cries out
my God my God why have you forsaken
me. Then in verse two I cry in the
daytime but you do not hear and in the
night season and am not silent. You know
did Jesus cry out day and night? Of
course he did. He cried out on the cross
in the day and the garden of Gethsemane
cried out at night. Yeah. Then a little
bit later on, you have the very words
that the enemies of Jesus spoke at the
foot of the cross. They shoot out the
lip. This verse seven, they shake their
heads saying, "He trusted in the Lord.
Let him rescue him. Let him deliver him
since he delights in him." Those are
almost the identical words that his
enemy spoke at the foot of the cross.
Then it speaks, "All my bones are out of
joint." There's no place that says that
that happened to David. My heart melts
within me. Well, when the spear was
pierced, pierced the heart of Jesus, you
know, his his heart melted. Uh, then it
says a little bit later on in verse 16,
they pierced my hands and my feet.
There's no record of that happening to
David. Yeah. And then you have a little
bit late, they divide, verse 18, they
divide my garments among them. There's
no event in the life of David where that
happened. Yeah. Uh and then standing in
the midst of a great congregation in the
second part of the psalm. You know,
there's no there's no evidence that that
happened to David. Yeah. And so this is
a psalm of
David, but almost everything in this
psalm never happened to David. And so
the question is, are we supposed to look
to someone with whom it did happen?
Amen. You know, the same is the same is
true of Isaiah 53. Yeah. You know, how
can you apply Isaiah 53 to Israel? Yeah,
there's no way you can do it if you're
honest in the way you read it. You know,
it speaks about not having any comeless
comelessness. This servant of the Lord,
it says in verse four, stricken, smitten
by God and afflicted, wounded for our
Was Israel wounded for our
transgressions? That's that's where I
bruised for our iniquities. Yes. Uh, a
little bit later on it says, "The Lord
has laid on him the iniquity of us all."
Did he Can that apply to Israel? Verse
seven, he was oppressed and he was
afflicted. And then a little bit later
on in verse eight, it says, "For he was
cut off from the land of the living."
Yes. For the transgressions of my people
he was stricken. Verse 10 says, "Yet it
pleased the Lord to bruise him. He, the
Lord, has put him to grief. When you
make his soul an offering for sin, see,
he was offered for sin. And so you go
through Isaiah 53, you say, "Come on
now." Yeah. How can you say that this
applies to Israel? It's impossible if
you're honest in the way that you read
the passage. Yes. Well said. And that's
what jumped out at me. Particularly
Isaiah 53 verse 4, verse 6, verse 10,
verse 12 talks about him bearing the
iniquities of of us all. Israel didn't
bear Israel had a problem dealing with
our own iniquity, let alone Yeah, that's
right. Iniquities of of us all. So
there's no way you can massage this to
make it fit. Uh you could say it came
out of context. And that's the same
argument that this person that I was
talking to said that's out of context.
Well, the the context is the suffering
savior. That's the context for this for
this for this passage. Uh out of context
is trying to make it to try to massage
it to squeeze it into deal with Israel
and it simply does not. Beside the fact
all the verses say he he he not they hey
but even if you blow that off the fact
that Israel did not suffer for our sins
uh Jesus suffered and died for our sins
and that's very very plain in Isaiah 53.
And and I like what uh uh pastor Salasar
brought up and that is the veil. Mhm.
That is over their over their heart. Um
and and it says that when they're
converted to Christ, the veil is taken
away. Sudden the Old Testament without
Christ Yeah. cannot be understood. Yeah.
Not really. It's impossible to
understand it. Yeah. But once you you
once you accept Christ as your savior,
the veil that keeps you from seeing
Christ in the Old Testament is removed.
Yes. And suddenly you see the light.
Yeah. And you see Christ in every
chapter, every page. Uh even in books
where his name is not mentioned per se,
he is there. Amen. But again, the veil
has to be removed. You know, pastors and
pastor, when we go to the Bible, we have
to be honest with ourselves. You know,
otherwise it says, take away any
preconceived notion that you may have
and take away any sense of your own
selfrighteousness. Approach God humbly
and with prayer. and God will be the the
revealer of truth to you. But if you
come with a lot of preconceived stuff,
you're gonna go off track because to try
to pull Christ out of the Old Testament,
first of all, it's an impossibility if
you're honest. And secondly, if you try
to do it, it's going to lead you down
certain paths and rabbit holes that you
would not do if you put Christ where he
belongs. We have to say like Samuel
said, "Speak Lord." Yes. For your
servant hearth. Amen. And amen. Pastor,
you got anything else? I was just, you
know, in closing, I would say that it's
it's important that we pray for Jewish
or or people that are in Judaism because
I believe that, you know, they need to
be uh they need to open their eyes to
the truth that we were mentioning. And
and when you have the desire to know the
truth, you are going to be led by the
Holy Spirit to understand these things.
Just like Nathaniel, you know, when he
was searching the scriptures sincerely
and the Lord saw that and he had
questions about Jesus, you know, him.
But as he was sincerely looking for the
truth, the Lord spoke to his heart. The
same thing happened with Paul. He was
uh, you know, a defender of the
tradition of the Jewish nation and the
rabbis and all these things. when he had
an encounter with Christ, he realized
and he like you was mentioning pastor,
you know, he saw how the Old Testament
really confirms everything and and and
you know about Christ and his mission,
who who he was. And so we had to pray
for him. And I think that you need to do
a lot of David. He needs to do a lot of
intercession for this friend and just
find you know uh a moment to speak to
him to to be willing to receive the word
of God even if it's the Old Testament
just by itself but to be open to what it
says so that he like the example of the
those two men that went in the walk to
Emmos as he was when Jesus you know
Jesus started to talk to them from the
very beginning from you know the
scriptures and spoke of the scriptures
the things that we talked about himself
they were finally convinced by the word
of God that Jesus was the Messiah. So I
think that David needs to do that part
of saying Lord help me to be a channel
of light to this individual and and to
present from the Old Testament because
that's the main thing you know they want
to they want to tell you the Old
Testament doesn't speak of Jesus but if
you actually read through the whole Old
Testament you will find the evidence of
Christ time and time again. Amen and
amen. Let's try to squeeze in one last
one before our time is exhausted. This
is coming from Epha or EA uh location
Germany. So thank you for writing to us
from Germany. Um what marks the
beginning of marriage? Is it the vows or
consummation of the marriage? I am
asking because I have heard some pastors
say that the vows are not convol convo
probably compulsive that the marriage is
finalized until consummation. The
marriage is not complete. Does the Bible
have anything or something to say about
if yes, what is it? All right,
gentlemen. Well, Genesis itself gives us
a distinction between the marriage and
the consummation of the what you might
call the consummation of the marriage.
Uh God married Adam and Eve first and
then later in chapter 4 verse one it
says, "Now Adam knew his wife and she
conceived and bore a son." So, so um
basically the book of Genesis tells us
that God marries them. He establishes
the marriage covenant and then they have
sexual relations and of course the
result is Cain. Uh so the I believe that
a marriage begins when both of them say
I do. Yeah. That's where the marriage
covenant is entered into. Um you know we
can find an example in the covenant that
God made with Israel, right? Uh in
Exodus chapter 19, God says,"I want to
make a covenant with you folks. Uh if
you obey my voice and keep my covenant,
you'll be my special people above all
the nations of the earth." And then the
message is relayed to Israel by Moses.
And the people say, "We do." And at that
time, the covenant is made. Yes. Um and
so, uh it's it's the moment when the
vows are given and they promise to keep
themselves for one another that the
marriage actually takes place. Amen.
Amen. I think that's very clear. I uh
the the idea of the consummation being
the moment where the marriage starts is
more of a u you know tradition of of
maybe some churches or some groups that
have established that idea that a
marriage is not really a marriage until
there's this consummation. But when you
come before uh authority, even if it's
not a, you know, if you're not a
believer, but you go before a civil
authority and you are married before
that judge, for example, and you declare
that you're going to be married to that
individual, that's when the marriage
starts. Um, obviously, we want to
encourage people to do it before the
Lord and have the blessing of God before
they consider themselves to be in a
marriage situation. But we know that it
really before God when you make that
commitment to that individual it's it's
really the start of the marriage and the
consummation you know is just uh like
you said could be happening after you
know um there's examples in the in the
past where people were to war went to
war and they got married right before he
was going to leave and so they couldn't
consummate the marriage for many many
months or even years and yet they're
still been married. So that's why it's
important that we don't put the emphasis
on the consummation as the final uh nail
to make sure that this is the marriage
you know uh the bottom line is that the
marriage itself the covenant itself
uh gives them the right to have sexual
relations exactly in the sight of God.
Yeah. Um and you know some people say
well do I really need to get married?
Can we just say the vows one to the
other? Well, there's all kinds of
reasons why there needs to be a marriage
ceremony, right? Where both of them in
public say, I do, right? And when one
says, "I do, the other one says, I do."
Uh, then the pastor declares a man and
wife. And now they have the privilege of
have se having sexual relations. You
know, I like looking at it that way that
that the the the covenant, the vows give
you the privilege of sex, not not the
sexual relations overshadowing or
overpowering the the vows. The vows are
more important. And the fact that you do
it in public and you call upon God to to
witness. Sure. So when you call upon
God, that's the that's the the deal
maker, right? Then what happens later
on, that's something else. But you made
your you made your deal when you called
upon God to witness and what God has
joined together. Let no man put us
under. So it's it's a God designed it,
orchestrated it, so he gets to give us
the parameters and the rules that we
must follow if we're going to be. And
some people have unfortunately taken
this concept of consummation to
um to say well you know my marriage was
not really a marriage because we never
you know they married for maybe they got
married before they had a wedding
whatever and they did not consummate the
marriage and for a couple of months and
then they decide to divorce give an
example I have I know of a particular
case of that situation and they will say
well and we never consummated the
marriage so you know it doesn't count
But that's I think a a real you know big
mistake in the understanding of what the
marriage is. As you were mentioned
pastor you know you are before God
declaring to be ma man and wife you
are technically already married. If you
consummate the marriage or not for
whatever reason you still are married
for God and you should not separate
divorce yourself from that individual.
You have no right to do that. By the way
I I like to compare this is an analogy.
I've never liked the idea of parents
parents allowing their children to
partake of the Lord's supper without
being baptized.
Uh really the
baptism is the is the inauguration
ceremony. It's the covenant ceremony.
And then as a result you have the
privilege of partaking of the Lord's
supper. Uh it's it's not identical
because it's just an analogy of the
order in which we need to do things.
Exactly. When I was growing up, my
parents told me, you know, uh, when that
when I saw that that little piece of
bread coming by and the gravity by I
want that, not necessarily because it
pointed to Christ, but because I wanted
to eat it, right? And so and so that's
similar to to the other. Amen. I like
that. Well, again, our time has fast
slipped into eternity. Allow me in
closing to wish you both grace and peace
through our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ. We'll see you again soon.
Bye-bye and God bless.
[Music]